juste un petit mot
les délibérations il ya unanimité il ya
eu des batailles farouche
non on était tous assez d'accord sur le
fond et sur ce qu'on attend du cinéma et
évidemment il ya eu
des petites exceptions des petites mais
globalement ouais on a en a je crois
qu'on est assez facile c'est très
satisfaits même du palmarès et nous
globalement journaliste moi j'ai
ressenti retrouve soudain agenda
n'allons pas du tout non c'était très
bien se fit nous on a ressenti fin mois
une sélection de qualité je trouve assez
exceptionnel vous aussi vous l'avez
ressenti dans ce qui nous était proposé
une montée
assez surpris du choix effectivement de
sa variété et
voilà je pense que le palmarès se
présente assez bien cette variété des
choses des du cinéma en général
merci beaucoup ce fils était parfait non
pas c'était parfait rassurez vous
bonsoir mesdames et messieurs de living
with you man bonsoir bienvenue
quel bonheur de vous retrouver quel
bonheur vous êtes tous vraiment
magnifique et messieurs les présidents
du jury
cole et eaton corp
maïwenn tu m'as tu m'as tu as cru en moi
comme personne avant tu m'a regardé
comme personne avant et je veux je me
dis que c'est difficile pour moi d'être
sur cette scène aujourd'hui 120 120
vincent cassel
je voudrais aussi dire à quel point je
remercie mon admiration pour les gens
que j'aime et se reconnaîtront ils sont
peu le jem à ce point là dans ma vie et
je voudrais aussi embrasser les deux
personnes que j'aime le plus sur la
terre qui sont mon fils marcel et ma
fille suzanne est aussi une pensée pour
ma maman qui est plus là et mon père qui
est plus là et quand je pense que c'est
fait tout ça pour qu'il me voie et ils
sont pas la voie lactée
alexandre dumas dumas fils parlait de
son père alexandre dumas père ils
disaient ses sept enfants que j'ai eus
sitôt eh ben je pense à mon père tu
ressens quoi cet instant précis vincent
jeu on est plusieurs
il n'y a pas on est plusieurs vincent y
en a un qui essaie d'aller ne pas
s'évanouir un autre qui essaie de dire
de remercier tous les gens qui m'ont qui
m'ont soutenu qu'elle était la peine
aussi parce qu'un film ne fait pas tout
seul et puis il ya un troisième qui peut
pas retenir ses larmes c'est c'est un
jour je n'oublierai jamais de ma vie
mais pas que pour moi pour les gens que
j'aime mais aussi pour les pour les pour
le public pour les gens qui vont pas
qu'ils vont voir parce qu'ils vont pas
me voir moi personnellement mais qui
vont voir défiler dans lequel je suis
depuis 30 ans et je voudrais partager ce
prix avec tout le monde je les remercie
du fond du coeur je suis vraiment un
homme bouleversé de bonheur bouleversé
boehner enfin deux de ce pitch vous avez
fait allusion bien sûr à votre père
michel audiard vous avez des idées là il
quand vous écrivez quand vous travaillez
vous savez comme moi je crois que perdre
un parent c'est on s'en remet jamais
donc moi je me suis jamais remis donc
voilà cette panne moteur et qu'on
représente quoi concrètement ça j'ai du
mal à froges pas ces bassins sa soeur
ses joueuses m'y attendais pas du tout a
lancé je suis donc je suis encore un peu
sous le coup de la surprise et j'ai pris
une espèce de coup de masse sur la terre
je verrai plus clair demain ou après
demain je sais pas
je ne me rends pas bien compte c'est
déjà une semaine que tu as marqué d'une
croix blanche j'ai envie verrai plus
jamais comme ça de ma vie puis comme je
les dis c'est vraiment enfin la villa
aujourd'hui elles dépassent mes rêves
j'ai jamais rêvé tout ça donc elle va au
delà des petits rêves que je pouvais
avoir c'est ça qui est qui est
bouleversant qui est unique et qui
n'arrive qu'une fois dans la vie je
pense